si vous voulez qu'on ne revienne plus il
faut les dénoncer viens où il se trouve
il faut nous aider Madame vous savez que
vous pouvez les dénoncer anonymement
le problème c'est que quand on dénonce
tout le monde est au courant ça
s'apprend la police les aides
le 180 c'est BM c'est nous qui répondons
non je préfère ne pas savoir
dans la forêt
[Musique]
bonjour Sébastien
salut Sébastian bienvenue à bord
[Musique]
le chef de la délégation c'est lui qui
va diriger l'enquête
[Musique]
on va aller directement là-bas non
oui mais on attend encore des
informations concrètes on a quelqu'un
sur place mais c'est pas encore très
clair
je suis avec les forces d'intervention
anti pirates de l'Amazonie
nous partons de Belém la principale
ville de l'estuaire du fleuve Amazone
nous sommes dans l'état du haras au
nord-est du Brésil direction la région
de brevès à 11h de bateau
c'est la première fois
ici c'est la route principale pour les
marchandises il y a surtout des produits
électroniques transit par là combien de
temps dure une attaque
ça dépend ça dépend du bateau oui de ce
qu'il transporte si c'est un navire de
croisière avec des passagers c'est
rapide il faut ça au maximum une heure
et disparaît maintenant si c'est du
combustible il leur faut quatre ou cinq
heures
les portables ne passent pas là-bas on
ne peut pas intercepter les appels dans
cette zone
on ne peut rien anticiper
sa passion ça me fait déjà arrivé de
tomber sur une attaque de les prendre en
flagrant délit
et d'ailleurs on a eu des échanges de
coupe
[Musique]
la Mazouni ce sont des centaines de
fleuves et rivières sur lesquels
transitent des navires de croisière des
pétroliers et des cargo de marchandises
et tous les bateaux sont devenus une
cible
depuis plus de 10 ans cette zone est
l'endroit qui connaît la plus forte
hausse d'acte de piraterie au monde
chaque année les morts se comptent par
centaines dans l'état du parrain
pour traquer les pirates 6 hommes de la
brigade fluviale qui couvre un
territoire grand comme la France
je vais embarquer 7 jours avec ses
enquêteurs chevronnés capables
d'intervenir dans une des zones les plus
hostiles de la planète et si c'est
impossible de les trouver
c'est une région
durant lesquels nous allons passer la
jungle au peigne fin et remonter la
piste de 150 barils de pétrole j'avais
entendu quelque chose madame non non
rien
il y a un truc qui cloche 7 jours
d'enquête avec un but arrêter les
pirates avant que leur butin ne soit
vendu au receleur
[Musique]
au Brésil les hommes de la brigade
fluviale sont surnommés les pitbulls
parce qu'ils sont incorruptibles et
qu'il ne lâchent jamais rien
c'est leur bateau
c'est le premier jour les seules
informations qui sont arrivées au QG de
la fluviale viennent de leurs
informateurs locaux
il y a deux jours un convoi s'est fait
braquer 150 baril d'essence l'attaque a
duré 6 heures l'équipage a été séquestré
à cet instant les pirates sont en train
de cacher le butin dans la jungle et
tente de le revendre
nous avons 48 heures de retard sur eux
non Jonathan
il y a combien de policiers dans cette
zone vous êtes combien on est pas
beaucoup
de travail pour nous c'est très dur les
actes de piraterie se concentre sur une
feuille très vaste et commissariats
locaux sont trop loin il nous aident un
peu mais c'est pas grand chose
en fait on fait l'enquête de A à Z
c'est nous qui vont tout faire sans rien
espérer de personne
ils sont corrompus
doit démarrer à monter Moria un village
connu pour son commerce illégal de
combustible
l'arrivée est prévue pour le lendemain
matin
j'ai 11 heures de voyage donc
je m'installais sur les opérations
anti-pirates chaque moment passé sur le
bateau est utilisé pour prendre des
forces
[Musique]
parfait nous allons vivre 7 jours sur ce
commissariat ambulant avec sa salle
d'interrogation
la salle à manger et la cuisine
pendant 7 jours le bruit du moteur ne
cessera jamais
[Applaudissements]
et l'odeur des sens sera omniprésente
[Musique]
les hommes qui m'accompagnent ne sont
pas bavards
ils savent que ces moments sont les
seuls instants de tranquillité qu'ils
auront avant longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le deuxième jour
nous arrivons à monter mauria dans la
région de brévès
trouvez les pirates il faut d'abord
chercher ceux qui rachètent leur butin
c'est la première étape de l'enquête
l'essence c'est la marchandise préférée
des pillards le produit le plus facile à
revendre chaque semaine des millions de
litres sont écoulés sur le marché noir
ils proviennent tous des attaques de
cargo
par radio un des habitants à signaler à
la brigade une livraison suspecte qui a
eu lieu la veille
les pirates et leurs complices on pour
habitude de se cacher parmi la
population
se promener ici c'est comme se promener
dans une favela
il y a les familles avec les enfants et
au milieu de tout ça des voleurs des
trafiquants et des assassins
en Amazonie la piraterie c'est comme la
mafia elle maintient les populations
sous pression
ici la seule loi valable c'est celle du
silence
[Musique]
bonjour messieurs
du groupement fluvial
des bidons qui sont là-bas c'est Adèle
d'accord c'est Adèle mais je veux
surtout savoir où il est
ici tout le monde se connaît ils sont
tous plus ou moins de la même famille
donc il ne parle pas
c'est l'odeur des sens qui a attiré les
policiers vers ce cabanon fermé à clé
on va chercher un pied de biche
[Musique]
il suffit de demander
à l'intérieur 3000 litres de combustible
c'est juste un stop pour la communauté
c'est de l'essence pour le village
avec vous
le seul moyen pour Arturo et ses hommes
de vérifier l'origine du stock
ce sont les factures
l'homme les possède toutes mais les
agents de la fluviale connaissent les
astuces pour transformer une marchandise
volée en marchandise légale
et la Russie
est illégal
le suspect va utiliser un autre argument
l'essence dans la région c'est vital il
faut toujours en avoir en stock
vous connaissez très bien notre
situation si quelqu'un tombe malade il
faut pouvoir le transporter on dépend
tous de combustible ici samedi dernier
une femme est venue ici en pleurant son
fils avait été mordu par un serpent elle
avait besoin d'essence pour l'amener à
l'hôpital de Santana alors si je n'ai
pas de stock qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
vous savez bien que c'est important mais
les policiers ont un doute aucun village
ne garde des stocks aussi important pour
les urgences
pas de souci
Arturo et ses hommes ne peuvent rien
faire ils savent que les factures sont
fausses mais ils n'ont pas les moyens de
le prouver ils savent aussi que les gens
de monter Montréal resteront muets
au revoir monsieur
mais en rejoignant leur QG un ratio va
attirer leur attention un bateau qu'ils
connaissent déjà
au lieu de nous
et cette écailles
vous pensez ce bateau exacts c'est pour
le transport de combustible
[Musique]
ah ok ouais tu as vu comme ça
bon interrogatoire
voilà alors on y va quoi
maintenant ils ont un élément pour
mettre la pression sur le suspect
tout va bien ouais ça va
est-ce que vous savez à qui est-ce
bateau
[Musique]
a déjà été repéré sur deux autres
attaques ah bon
votre communauté il y a plein d'essence
suspects
l'homme ne veut rien dire ou alors il ne
peut pas les pirates on pourra habitude
de menacer tous ceux qui partent à la
fluviale
les policiers vont alors proposer aux
habitants une porte de sortie
il suffit de nous dire qui est la
personne et où il habite
vous n'avez même pas besoin de venir
avec nous vous donner l'info et on va
parler avec lui
mais personne ne craque pour briser
l'omerta ils vont décider de frapper un
grand
très bien
les histoires vous n'avez rien
et des problèmes
ce coup de sang n’est en réalité que du
bluff
si on fait tout ça c'est pour essayer
de faire des petites saisies
et le coup de bluff va servirait payant
10 minutes plus tard la femme
propriétaire est en train de répondre
aux questions des enquêteurs
elle va lâcher un nom giovanno l'homme
qui a loué le bateau à plusieurs
reprises un pirate connu de leur service
les policiers savouillent la [__] c'est
à une nuit de navigation d'ici
c'est le début d'une course contre la
montre les pirates ont déjà commencé à
écouler leur butin s'ils arrivent à
vendre la totalité des 150 barils des
policiers ne pourront plus rien faire
c'est la deuxième étape de l'enquête
nous avons encore 24 heures de retard
sur eux ok on vient de se réveiller
[Musique]
par balle pour tout le monde cette fois
il faut frapper vite et fort nous
embarquons dans une navette rapide la
zone devons intervenir est une zone
pirate une zone sauvage et dangereuse où
tout le monde est armé
l'endroit où on va c'est un point
stratégique c'est un carrefour on peut
voir toutes les embarcations passées tu
verras sa maison à une vue panoramique
et c'est là-bas qu'une bande s'est
formée
nous sommes à 10 minutes de la maison du
pirate giovanno Arturo et ses hommes
sont inquiets il comptait arriver avant
le lever du jour pour le surprendre
[Musique]
à chaque fois qu'il croise quelqu'un sur
le fleuve leur chance diminue
oui ce créneau horaire n'est pas bon du
tout
ils utilisent des radios oui il y a du
réseau ici alors les gens qui ne voient
passer préviennent les pirates de notre
présence
la nuit
[Musique]
il nous entendent passer mais ils ne
savent pas qui c'est
si le pirate s'échappe dans la forêt il
ne le retrouveront pas
là-bas dans la clairière c'est sa maison
à côté ici est impossible si on ne
connaît pas le terrain finalement une
clairière permet à la brigade de
débarquer
ils ont perdu beaucoup de temps dans la
manœuvre la maison de giovanno est trop
loin pour le surprendre
[Musique]
il faut maintenant s'enfoncer dans la
jungle avec une crainte que l'homme qui
vienne arrêter et décider de ne pas fuir
et de les affronter
dans la maison il y a un homme il
n'offre aucune résistance
prend son identité il y a des armes à
l'intérieur je n'ai pas d'armes
restez là-bas
je vous dis ok on va vérifier ne vous
inquiétez pas où est-ce que tu as mis
tes papiers
c'est pas trop avec les autres documents
là-bas
votre nom complet Giovanni monte
à l'intérieur ils vont vérifier
l'identité de l'homme qu'ils viennent de
menotter il s'appelle bien Giovanni
c'est le petit frère de giovannon
mais ils vont aussi découvrir du
matériel électronique de grande valeur
et pas une seule facture
ils sont bien dans la maison d'une
famille de pirates
facture
tu n'as rien du tout [__]
va aller chercher tu as compris
giovanno s'est enfui dans la jungle il y
a peu de chance de le retrouver
mais les pitbulls n'abandonne jamais
et comme il s'est présenté avec un
prénom très proche on lui a mis les
menottes mais on a vérifié et c'est bien
son frère ou son cousin
Arturo et ses hommes décident
d'inspecter la zone il y a de fortes
chances que giovanno est caché les
barils d'essence près de chez lui
et là on s'enfonce vraiment mais alors
vraiment
dans la forêt
l'Amazonie est un des endroits les plus
hostiles de la planète la regarde ça
facile pour eux d'accoster
il en connaît tous les secrets les
hommes de la brigade fluviale doivent
rester sur leurs gardes
c'est impossible de les trouver
s'il faut s'enfoncer dans la jungle ils
doivent être sûrs de leur cours
cinquantaine de mètres des berges la
forêt a été piétinée
tout en bas
et la forte odeur des sens indique que
les barils étaient là la veille
avoir beaucoup de mouvements c'est
dingue
la cargaison volée était encore là il y
a moins de 24 heures mais Giovanni a été
prévenu de la descente de la brigade
avec ses hommes il a eu le temps de tout
déplacer
la police
c'est très difficile de recouper les
informations mais des fois on arrive à
Johnny
[Musique]
bon ben
il y a de la boue partout bon ça c'était
un peu de prévisible
de tous les jours donc mais
alors encore des bidon
on s'approche quoi des
pirates alors pour les trouver je sais
pas comment on va pouvoir faire
[Musique]
on va pas trop s'enfoncer là parce que
c'est déjà plus on est là
on est où là et puis nous tombons sur
une autre maison abandonnée
les pirates vivent souvent les uns à
côté des autres c'est plus pratique pour
la logistique des attaques
théorie là les gens sont partis dès
qu'ils ont su qu'on arrivait
dans cette maison
il n'y a plus rien à faire ici
avant de partir les policiers de la
fluviale vont interroger les habitants
une tentative qu'ils savent désespérer
si vous voulez qu'on revienne plus il
faut les dénoncer dire où il se trouve
il faut nous aider Madame vous savez que
vous pouvez les dénoncer anonymement
j'aimerais bien voir ça le problème
c'est que quand on dénonce tout le monde
est au courant ça s'apprend la police
les aides
non je préfère ne pas savoir
vous ne serez même pas y avoir
non merci je ne veux pas finir dans le
journal
si ceux qui parlent à la fluviale
disparaissent dans la forêt
on ne retrouve jamais leur corps
nous rejoignons le QG l'enquête est au
point mort
à monter Moria nous avons trouvé 3000
litres d'essence provenant du braquage
nous avons aussi trouvé un des bateaux
qui a servi à l'attaque
et le nom de celui qui a tout organisé
il s'appelle giovanno il se cache dans
la forêt avec la marchandise volée
c'est le troisième jour
la brigade fluviale n'a plus qu'une
seule carte à jouer inspecter le bateau
qui a été attaqué et interroger
l'équipage
nous allons remonter le fleuve pendant
deux jours
deux jours pour reprendre des forces et
faire la lessive
plus facile
pour moi
[Musique]
cinquième jour le temps presse les
pirates sont en train d'écouler leur
butin on a combien là 8 0 pour eux
dans 50% des affaires de piraterie
l'équipage est complice des assaillants
voici le bateau qui a été pillé
c'est la troisième étape de l'enquête
Arturo et ses hommes vont recouper les
témoignages des 12 membres de l'équipage
ils vont d'abord les prendre en photo
pour pouvoir les confondre plus tard
avec d'éventuelles témoins
[Musique]
et puis les interrogatoires commencent
un par un les convoyeurs pour raconter
leur version des faits
et vous avez une idée de ce qui s'est
passé vous êtes toujours en train de
chercher
on est en train de les interroger
d'après les premiers éléments on pense
que les membres de l'équipage sont
impliqués
bien avec moi on va parler un peu plus
loin on va un peu s'éloigner de ça
reste là-bas
parce que pour l'instant on a que des
indices il faut rester discret pour
qu'ils soient en confiance
c'est une vraie enquête
étape par étape
je vais t'expliquer comment ça se passe
généralement ce bateau était chargé
d'essence d'autres bateaux peuvent
transporter du matériel électronique ils
ont plein de containers
généralement il y a un commentaire
c'est celui qui achète toutes les
marchandises brûlées et qui va les
revendre souvent l'attaque est organisée
en totalité par le commanditaire
une course contre la montre va se
dérouler dans les prochaines heures la
fluviale doit absolument trouver les 150
baril d'essence avant qu'il ne soit
revendus la cadence des interrogatoires
va s'accélérer
ils ont appelé l'armée en renfort
les taux se resserre autour de
l'équipage les policiers sont maintenant
certains de son implication
cette facture c'est celle qui vous ont
été donnés par le fournisseur
mais vous avez mis trois jours pour
venir jusqu'ici
ce qu'il leur faut maintenant c'est le
nom du commanditaire celui qui a tout
organisé le grand patron des pirates
plus dangereux
[Musique]
et d'autres qui aident la communauté
dans les deux cas les habitants ne
parlent pas
Arturo veut me montrer l'endroit où
l'équipage était soi-disant séquestré
dans les enquêtes sur les actes de
piraterie il faut toujours se méfier des
apparences
[Musique]
exactement c'est un défi mais ça fait
partie d'une stratégie ils en ont fait
un autre ici la bande des tatouées
c'est comme une signature de leur
organisation
mais il ne s'agit pas de la bande des
tatouées c'est pour détourner notre
attention sur ce gang mais ce n'est pas
ce groupe c'est une autre organisation
criminelle qui est derrière tout ça
c'est
ici aussi oui ici aussi
je vous ai pas dit ça fait 5 jours que
nous sommes partis de Belém et depuis
cinq jours ces viandes bouillies patates
matin midi et soir alors pendant que les
enquêteurs interrogent l'équipage je
m'autorise un petit écart
de l'autre côté du fleuve les militaires
qui viennent d'arriver ont trouvé un
petit coin de paradis
[Musique]
on va manger une cantine chez l'habitant
de quoi enfin varier le menu
j'ai voulu marquer le coup
[Musique]
il faut pas dire à la nage
au menu bœuf grillé crevettes
et une spécialité locale
[Musique]
ça c'est la saillie c'est un des fruits
les plus nutritif au monde
et locaux ils mangent
partout dans le monde
et c'est devenu super cher
[Musique]
voilà
tu as déjà goûté sous cette forme oui
comme ça oui mais c'est un peu
ah merde non
c'est bon comme ça oui ça va te plaire à
la brésilienne avec du sucre c'est bon
[Musique]
les militaires aussi profitent de ce
repas inespéré
et je vais en apprendre beaucoup sur la
faune locale
dans le fleuve il y a des piranhas dans
le fleuve des piranhas
il y avait des piranhas tu serais déjà
ici en bas
[Musique]
qui te rentre dans l'urètre
c'est une sorte de verre
et qui se nourritaient
bon ben moi je crois que je vais pas
rentrer à la nage
[Musique]
vous m'attendez
il y a un truc qui peut me rentrer dans
l'urètre et j'ai pas du tout envie
trois heures du matin
l'équipage craque
leur histoire ne tient plus
Arthur au termine les interrogatoires
avec les menottes en évidence
à partir de cet instant
c'est convoyeurs de la marine marchande
sont considérés comme des pirates
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu
toujours la même chose les vrais
criminels on n'arrive pas les choper
les policiers sont pas trop corrompus
ils ont passé de moyens pour aller
chercher
les seuls qu'on arrive à choper
c'est les mecs qui qui sont sous-payés
et qui se disent bah en voyant tous les
marchandises tout l'argent qui qui
transit ils disent je vais en croquer un
peu quoi là le mec en fait il risque 50
prisons minimum entre 5 et 15
c'est le capitaine du bateau qui va tout
avouer ils ont reçu 1200 euros des
pirates 100 euros chacun pour cette
somme ils vont tous finir derrière les
barreaux
[Musique]
sixième jour nous mettons le cap sur la
ville d'afoua
maintenant la brigade fluviale a le nom
du commanditaire l'homme qui a tout
planifié le patron de giovanno c'est la
quatrième étape de l'enquête
on va commencer par faire le tour des
bateaux
et localiser ceux qui ont transporté le
soluté
normalement on va pouvoir retrouver le
commanditaire ok celui qui a tout acheté
il faut faire vite la ville d'afwa est
suffisamment grande pour écouler 150
barils de combustible en quelques jours
ici nombreux sont ceux qui ont besoin
d'essence et ils sont tous prêts à
l'acheter moins cher au marché noir
ok merci
le propriétaire de la station vous avez
les factures de tout ça
les factures
ils nous ont donné
il avait acheté dans le coin
je suis allé juste avant
la ville est déjà inondée par les sens
volés et tout indique qu'elle provient
du même endroit
c'est un bateau
station essence
[Musique]
il doit être chez lui est-ce que tu as
son téléphone
non j'ai pas de téléphone ici je n'ai
pas pris avec moi
sa maison la prochaine à droite c'est la
belle maison avec les fleurs une
barrière et un auvent
ouais c'est ça la grande maison superbe
les policiers savent maintenant où est
l'homme qui a acheté l'essence au
pirates et qu'il a revend dans toute la
ville
c'est un notable il est intouchable
cette fois les policiers vont devoir y
aller avec des pincettes
[Musique]
donc on est chez le normalement chez le
receleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu l'as vu
c'était un travail de fourmi
là normalement c'est le bout de la
chaîne
pour échapper à la prison l'homme va
parler il va indiquer à la brigade
fluviale où se trouve giovanno le pirate
et les 150 barils d'essence
demain c'est la dernière étape de
l'enquête
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas question cette fois qu'une fuite
fasse capoter leur mission
à partir de maintenant les pitbulls ne
donnent aucune information
[Musique]
c'est le septième jour nous sommes à 30
minutes de bateau de la planque de
Giovanna
[Musique]
intervention a lieu la aucun des
policiers n'est encore jamais allé alors
ils embarquent avec eux un guide
qu'ils ont pris soin de cagoulé
si cet homme est reconnu
sera exécuté par les pirates
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 16h30
il fait 45 degrés
s'il rate leur cou
toute enquête tombe à l'eau
[Musique]
encore une fois la planque est vide
fermer la porte
cette porte est fermée à cliquer il y a
des trucs dedans
[Musique]
giovanno et ses hommes sont visiblement
partie de manière précipitée ils ont
pris des vêtements et de la nourriture
de quoi se cacher dans la forêt pendant
plusieurs jours
c'est le téléphone
[Musique]
si le téléphone sonne c'est que les
pirates ne sont pas loin
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les policiers décident de prendre un
revers les pirates et couper leur fuite
dans la forêt
[Musique]
ils sont là ils sont cachés dans la
forêt
nous ne sommes plus qu'à quelques mètres
de
les barils
sont là
[Musique]
ils sont partis et comment vous allez
faire pour récupérer tout ça je vais par
la prendre de l'autre côté
les pitbulls se séparent tous pour
couvrir le maximum de terrain
les pirates se sont enfuis
mais il reste une petite chance de les
attraper
problème dans la jungle il ne faut pas
se précipiter les pirates ont pu monter
un guet-apens
les écorces
[Musique]
que là si je me perds c'est foutu là je
sais pas où on est je sais pas quelle
direction on a pris
[Musique]
et là il y a des moustiques mais c'est
comment dire j'ai le cadet de mes soucis
[Musique]
la progression est difficile
et finalement nous tombons sur une autre
partie de la marchandise celui-là
[Musique]
pour sécuriser leur butin les pirates ne
cachent jamais la totalité au même
endroit moi ils ont trouvé une centaine
une centaine baril d'essence
[Musique]
il y a un bateau qui est juste là-bas
et le cache ici
[Musique]
dans un ruisseau difficile d'accès
une partie de l'équipe a capturer un des
pirates qui montait la garde
[Musique]
pendant deux jours les policiers vont
récupérer l'essence voler
[Musique]
mission accomplie pour les pitbulls de
l'Amazonie ils ont retrouvé l'essentiel
de la marchandise
seul le vin barils de combustible avait
été revendu
[Musique]
comment commencer à on fait comme ça on
fait comme ça
c'est bon
ils sont contents
c'est une grosse prise
c'est une grosse prise c'est une grosse
photo c'est un grand moment
7 jours après mon départ les hommes de
la brigade fluviale sont repartis en
mission
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on en a arrêté deux qui vont
d'ailleurs
en Amazonie il y a une attaque pirate
tous les deux jours
90% des marchandises volées ne sont
jamais retrouvés
[Musique]